[Music]
boeing and airbus the world's two
biggest play manufacturers
neck and neck for years america versus
europe this year
things are a little different see while
both companies have suffered from
cancelled orders and supply chain was
caused in part by the cove pandemic
boeing has also had to deal with this an
indonesia passenger plane crashing into
the sea the new boeing 737 crashing the
us is grounding all boeing 737 max
planes the turmoil has left boeing in a
position of weakness one that airbus has
been trying to capitalize on and that's
got people asking what can boeing do to
catch up well let's find out
so i'm at farnborough air show and i
first started coming here over a decade
ago and every single year the race
between these two manufacturing giants
has dominated the skies and the
headlines the one question that everyone
normally asks is who secured more orders
and nudged ahead of the other but this
year boeing has a bigger challenge ahead
and if there's one person who knows
about the scale of that challenge it's
our boeing reporter andrew tangle boeing
came into this year's farm borough
2 000 narrow body jet orders behind
airbus
they are fairly far behind at least in
the narrow body market
while orders for the max have been
picking up since it won regulatory
approval in most countries in china a
country that boeing chief executives
called crucial recovery has been slow as
the plane was only recertified in
december and is yet to return to the
skies on top of the hurdles with the 737
max boeing has also been plagued with
production issues and hasn't been able
to deliver its wide body plane the 787
dreamliner
and that has left the door open for
airbus
so really what we're seeing is is this
dynamic where airbus is coming to the
show on a much stronger ground on a much
stronger footing than they really have
been you know at least since i've been
covering the industry but for much
longer as well that's ben katz wsj's
airbus reporter and he told me that when
the pandemic struck airbus cut its
production rates from 60 a320 jets a
month to just 40. however airbus is now
saying you know by 2025 we want to get
to a rate of 75 a month that is higher
than we were before the pandemic higher
than those ambitions that they had the
strategy appears to be paying off as
airbus recently won an enormous order of
nearly 300 a320s from chinese carriers
even without that they're leading boeing
on orders for narrow-body aircraft 59 to
41
according to data from ascend but eber
still has issues of its own airbus at
running at rate 75 it's just
really really ambitious and it allows
them to to sell a lot more aircraft you
know even a few months ago speaking to
abba's you know head of sales you know
he was complaining we just can't make
these aircraft fast enough
so is there a way back for boeing
well for starters the company is hopeful
that it will finally get regulatory
approval for the new variants of its 737
max planes and sales of the 787
dreamliner are set to pick up once the
company can start delivering them again
stan deal the commercial chief at boeing
suggested that once the dreamliner is
able to be delivered again after a
drought of nearly two years that more
orders for those planes will follow too
but as boeing is still hundreds of
orders behind and is still operating in
a world of supply chain snarls it's
anybody's guess how long it could take
for balance to be restored to the
duopoly boeing's got time to catch up
beyond just the air show customers want
to see
boeing execute that means
planes without production issues
delivered on time reliably and so forth
whatever happens one plane manufacturer
that we'll be watching closely is
chinese state-owned comac who is about
to release a narrow body plane of its
own the company may not have much of an
impact on the duopoly in the short term
but the potential for a heavily
subsidised chinese plane manufacturer to
disrupt these two industry giants in the
decades to come is very real
you